[Musique]
ils étaient 4 178 coureurs a participé à
la deuxième édition du trail de villèle
ce dimanche 12 décembre une course de 24
km avec comme lieu de départ le fond de
mer de saint-paul et une arrivée au
musée historique de villèle courir en
liberté une épreuve qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre de la commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
en tant que conseillère départementale
délégué aux activités de pleine nature
et passionnés de trail valérie rivière
était présente parmi les participants
je salue les pénibles
libre qu'on a aurait trouvé les valeurs
libérales
et puis
après parcourir tout le cap la houssaye
la savane c'était quand même un peu dur
parce qu'ils en moins d'essence
il a fait très chaud mais voilà c'est un
ami l'image que les
marrons les esclaves marrons vivait
cette difficulté donc à monter dans les
montagnes on n'a pas couru en 9 et notre
chemin de croix aujourd'hui sur 24 km
pour arriver sur ce beau site du musée
de villèle et je salue l'organisation et
les bénévoles et tous les agents du
département fait super beau l'aviation
vraiment rien à redire c'était un
plaisir de participer à une course
organisée par le département sur les
traces de l'histoire
de l'esclavagé ça fait mal c'était une
course faisait mal mais une source
extraordinaire on a vu la mer on a vu la
savane la biodiversité la richesse de
tous sur ce que les espaces naturels
peuvent nous offrir en si peu de temps
et bien nous faire du mal donc c'était
très chouette et c'est une vraiment une
belle manière de finir l'année et de
fêter le 20 décembre ici
l'écho de sarran projets écologiques et
économiques nous cette année on a mis en
place y prend place donc c'est la faute
de l'écossais c'est ça aussi ça fait
déjà trois ans exactement le tiff
annoncé que les que 200 la personne
achète un dossard il vient tous
concourir il va pas changer sur
l'échangé seront de sang ni assez
inquiets hier à saint-paul et tout ça
donc c'est vraiment très écologique et
l'avantagé avec ce toutes les courses
c'est benjamin allouche qui a remporté
le trail isabelle lamy chez les femmes
la russe des british déroulée en
présence de kevin mais hier encore mal
chanté des calculs que l'ensemble de
l'équipe de france d'athlétisme
[Musique]